yeah guys her stuff is good she's very
entertaining and like she's got a really
good like head on her shoulders like i
really like that your stuff is like
like sometimes you watch red pill stuff
and it's very much like doomsday you
know what i mean a little bit and you're
like very positive like you you frame
the wall in like a positive way like i
saw a piece of content um from you the
other day that was saying like you don't
have to look at the wall as a bad thing
it just means you know it's how you
structure your life the wall is only a
problem if you're in denial about aging
as a woman
that's the only the only time it's an
issue or if all of your content and
character
is solely invested in your physique
that's when you struggle as a woman
every well-rounded woman i know isn't
really worried about the wall because
they're setting up their lives
accordingly for when they're gonna be 40
50 60. and you know for any woman that
thinks that the wall doesn't exist do
you really think that your grandma is as
hot as she was at 18. like i just want
to know
yeah and um
no and i don't know why like it's okay
to have other things in life other than
looks like it's not the end-all be-all
it's just basically saying you're
getting gonna get less hot the older you
get which is like kind of a given
yeah and i think too that i'm a little
bit lucky that i wasn't born necessarily
a solid 9 or 10. and every time i say
this people want to come in like oh my
god you're so pretty no i've been to
miami okay i know what's up i know
what's up and so for me i think also i
was overweight for a long time i
actually lost 45 pounds so i think that
that helped me to keep a real level head
and not over invest in my looks but i'm
going to say the looks are important
don't get me wrong i'm just glad that i
don't have that everlasting genetic
makeup to where i'm going to be super
hot and attractive and maybe like a tad
delusional at 30 or 40 because i see
that happen a lot to very attractive
women
i see that too it's like their whole
value is based in their looks and they
don't really work on like developing
other skills like communication
being not not always not always but like
i see it a lot in super attractive girls
yeah and there's always that argument
not all women not all women i get it we
all know a tall asian but what we really
talk about is right we mostly just talk
about men and women on average that
that's it and unfortunately on average
men find women around age 23 24 to be
the most attractive and on average women
in the west find men to be attractive
when they're
on average four years older than them so
these things they just exist we're not
making it up i wish we were making it up
but that is not the situation
yeah
so um let's talk about how you kind of
found the red pill
so you were married before right
yeah could you tell me about that a
little bit
yes so i was married for five years but
i i got married out of scarcity i got
married for stability
it i wish it was a beta bucks situation
i think you know what it was i had
gotten married off of potential because
i think deep down inside i knew that i
wanted to stay home with my kids i
wasn't sure how long i was going to stay
home but things had happened within that
marriage
once my spouse at the time got out of
the military where he got really regular
really quick and i started getting very
concerned because it was apparent to me
that i was going to be working for the
rest of my natural born life because
when you present a man with divorce and
then he's quick with it and starting to
change
well he's only changing because of
what's on the line it would have been
nice if the things that i had said for
the past year and a half were taken
seriously then i wouldn't be in that
position but it was it was a real
learning experience for me and i ended
up finding out that i was attracted to
traditionally masculine men and i didn't
expect that because a lot of the women
that i was around growing up was born to
a lower socioeconomic status they just
tell you to marry a good stable guy they
don't say anything about that attraction
piece which is very important to me
yeah i don't know why we don't ever
really talk about like traditional
masculinity at all like it's almost
frowned upon it's what i found like if
you ever say i like a masculine man
it's always
like almost there's always pushback when
i talk to like girls my age about that
anyways
well there's pushback but then look at
who they're dating it's like athletes
that are six foot tall you can just
smell the testosterone seeping off of
him from across the room so like what a
woman says she's attracted to versus who
she actually ends up dating is two very
different things but when you when you
use that same lens as women women
they don't understand so this is what i
keep hearing is that well
what men are attracted to is different
than what they say they're attracted to
but women are not understanding that who
a man will sleep with is going to be
different than who he will marry
two different types of chicks so as much
as i would love i would love the
attention from
dressing a lot more sexier maybe pushing
up my breasts maybe wearing smaller
clothes i would like that just because
it does make you feel a little bit good
and validated i'm just going to keep it
a stack okay
but
the the attention that i'm getting from
men isn't going to be the attention that
i want and i know every time that i
dress kind of skimpy i know that i have
to be like prepared for the nonsense
that's going to come my way because i'm
athletic so i'll go out and my sports
bra and my tights if i'm just on the
move on the move i don't have time to do
a bathroom and change i get everything i
need done in a day but i know that
that's going to put me in a position to
be cat called and i actually actually
don't like that that much so i try not
to do that
but yeah i mean
even though i'm on the the boring side
of things the housewife side of things i
just have to remember that all i need to
worry about is if my man at home is
attracted to me i don't need the world
looking at me per se although it does
feel good
that's so that's very honest right
that's what i love about ellie she's
very honest
um okay so you ended up getting divorced
from the first guy and then how did you
meet your now husband
so i knew him i knew him the whole time
i was married and this is what throws
people off because it comes into like
well the beta orbiter maybe she was
seeing somebody on the side wasn't
anything like that because my fiance is
very rigid if if anybody met him in real
life for five minutes they would know
just how rigid this dude is so he
outranked me and my spouse at the time
so we never socialized
out of the office which would be the
military we were both in the military he
was an officer i wasn't listening you're
not supposed to hang out and also in the
military too
it's like perception is reality so if
you're hanging out with a hot little
young honey people are gonna think
things about you people are gonna assume
things and you're gonna get some heat at
work because of that whole well like is
the man abusing this power kind of thing
also infidelity's rampant it's illegal
to be unfaithful in the military i don't
know if people know that you can
actually write it at work
yeah yeah you can get a write-up at work
if you
cheat on your spouse as a service member
so people don't like to take those kinds
of risks i see people cheat on
deployment though
um so i used to work for him he was a
medical provider he was always very kind
to me and he wasn't condescending and i
liked that because you make a certain
rank and these guys just have really
huge heads
and we always treated me like a person
and i always learned from him so when my
divorce rolled around i had i maintained
a friendship with him
after i got out of the military so i get
out of the military i get divorced and
all of a sudden he looked like a snack
so we just built a friendship and i know
i know how that looks but like life is
not black and white and it happens like
monkey branching happens whether i knew
i was doing it or not if that's how i
was going to look and i i don't mind
because like i i'm the one in the
relationship am i really going to care
what these people are thinking when i'm
60 like i got the man of my dreams it
happens
no that's it you are so cute like the
way you talk about him is literally and
i can tell he like really supports what
you're doing